[Music]
so a lot of games came out this year and
I tried to keep up with them and I think
I did a good job um not all of them
really sort of stuck with me but one
that really did stick with me was
transistor I think super giant games did
a really good job on the uh piggybacking
on Bastion I love the combat in that
game it's so just like creative you can
stop time and sort of plan out your
moves and chain them together or you can
ort of just go in and whack them one at
a time um I really like that strategy
element to it and it sort of added to
the whole like Mystique of the
atmosphere like you don't really know a
lot about the city and you don't really
know about like a lot about these
enemies and that sort of ties back into
this story um a lot of people I know
didn't really like the story didn't care
about the story but what I love about it
is that it's sort of revealed very like
very slowly and very like sort of
discreetly like you really have to dig
around and like go into like the little
like the mailboxes and like read the
letters and like listen to the
transistors he's talking to and stuff
like that and I love that about it it
was so so just poignant and like
powerful in how little it did like it
said a lot by doing not very
much you better go so chel had four
games come out this year finish this
year start this year if you're counting
tales and Game of
Thrones Mr Wolf but um what really got
me about uh The Wolf Among Us is it was
very like human in like a mystical sort
of way like I really liked the way that
you had to struggle uh as Big B either
balancing like people's respect for you
and whether or not they like listen to
you and help you or whether or not like
[__] got done because everyone hated him
for a reason and you were trying to do
what you thought was right and you know
get rid of the bad people in fabl town
but at the same time you had to balance
like getting snow white to like you and
getting other people to trust you so you
could get your job done and nothing you
did seemed to be the right answer that
would make everyone happy and I really
liked that sort of uh that power
struggle that was really appealing to me
also character of the Year Mr Toad like
how can you not like a talking toad
wearing freaking like sweatpants and
like a Mr Rogers cardigan who swears at
you with an Irish accent character of
year here's a slum Lord character of the
Year
[Music]
toad I'm going to Bravely Default my
next choice to Bravely Default that was
stupid joke rly default a really solid
Japanese role playing game I love jrpg
so of course this is on my list um not
really very many good jrpgs came out
this year but I feel like Brave lead
fault stands out and that it does what a
lot of jrpgs aren't doing very well
better than they've been doing for a
long time I think it's doing Final
Fantasy better than Final Fantasy big
talk I know um but job classes then job
sub job other job things that you can do
from other jobs boom amazing it's like
tailoring your own Warrior and that's
what I loved about it and the story the
characters are really well rounded um I
thought I really felt for them I thought
the scripting was really good and I know
that it sort of falls off and like the
latter maybe half or third of the game
where you sort of have to go back and
like do a lot of stuff over but I feel
like the overall game doesn't suffer for
that because you're working with these
you know amazing job classes you're
making yourself better you're um getting
little bits and pieces of the story that
are still coming together through that
part and I just love it it's my favorite
role playing game that came out this
[Music]
year
so Child of Light I think is a special
case it's a very good um example of what
a small team can do sort of given the
time to get creative and try things that
people haven't done before um Child of
Light hooked me because they were
marketing it as a jrpg inspired uh game
like with combat system like grandia 2
which is a really solid jrpg um I fell
in love with that game I played it I've
played it maybe four or five times start
to finish
on like normal mode then like the
hardcore mode and it's just this like
really beautiful story about this girl
sort of growing into her own it's one
gorgeous um I want pink hair two I think
the characters are really Charming like
something that sort of speaks to me for
games short games it's a short game but
something that really works for short
games like that is the way that they had
sort of all these really really quirky
really strange characters surrounding um
Aurora the main character and it's also
sort of a story about your love for your
family and what you're sort of like born
to do I don't know it's like all of that
together really makes it a really like
sweet fairy tale and it's written in
rhyme the writers on that game total
respect for them they wrote the whole
damn thing in in rhyme and I loved it I
thought it was Charming I thought it was
super
[Music]
cool oh God that game is just so awesome
I literally zoned out thinking about
that game trying to explain it
[Music]
sorry Middle Earth Shadow of Mordor um
I'm obviously a huge Lord of the Rings
fan I've made no secret about that so I
love that IP to death but what I loved
about Shadow of Mordor is it took that
it took token's world and wasn't
beholden to it and its tropes and things
but rather challenged it and sort of the
whole thing in his head toan's always
warning us about using the weapon of the
enemy against the enemy and um that's
what the people in the Le say not to do
but that's exactly what talian doing in
Shadow of Mordor and then you sort of
have this really beautiful look at like
Mordor before Sauron really corrupted it
and on top of all that you have this
Nemesis system which is to me like the
nextg system like that to me says like
this is a nextg game I love that all of
the Orcs have like different
personalities and different weaknesses
and they talk to you right before you
like fight them and if they kill you
they become more powerful and then later
in the game you're sneaking up on them
and you can hear them talking [__] about
you and I just think that's like the
coolest thing it feels like a living
breathing world when you combine the way
that they've written and designed it
with that enemy system that's just
constantly evolving and changing based
on your actions um I feel like I'm
actually making an impact on that world
from some way and also it's just like
super freaking fun to like come in you
come in and you're super weak and the
game challenges you to get better and by
the time you're you know super powerful
by the end of the game you're like
flipping around in like firefights of
like 20 Orcs just like in heads and
stabbing them the neck and just flipping
around and it's like sool I feel like I
am like a Lord of the Rings hero like
bashing work skull in in
morar so
good